hey Klick so J fah erstmal herzlichen
Glückwunsch zu deinem Chart Erfolg und
jetzt habe ich drei Fragen an
dich wie sieht es mit talion 2 aus wird
da was kommen oder arbeitest du zur Zeit
an anderen
Projekten was mich noch interessieren
würde ist best stellst du dir deine
Zukunft in fün bis 10 Jahren
vor 2011 haben wir sehr viele wie unser
B sagen würde sprechgesangsartisten i
allen Releas gibt es irgendwas was du
davon gefeiert hast ich würde mich
freuen wenn du all meine Fragen
beantworten würdest und ja das war's
jetzt von mir und ich wünsche dir auf
jeden Fall weiterhin viel Erfolg mit
deiner Musik peace korrekt auf jeden
Fall sympathischer dude an der Stelle so
danke erstmal dass du mir glückwünscht
für den chaderfolg finde ich sehr cool
dass du das mitverfolgt hast zu deinen
Fragen also das Dinge mitalion ist halt
so es liegt nicht nur an mir es liegt
auch an snager aber ich bin auf jeden
Fall gewählt und die Leute sollten Augen
und offenhalten wann und wie das
erscheint kann ich dir so nicht sagen
die zweite Frage ist wo ich mich in 5
bis 10 Jahren sehe 5 Jahre scheint mir
ein bisschen zu nah aber wenn ich dir
sagen würd 10 Jahre dann stelle ich mir
schon vor dass ich eine eigene Familie
habe meine eigenen Kids das wäre mein
Wunsch und wie weit ich den dann bis
dahin erfüllt habe mein Freund werden
wir dann wahrscheinlich zusammen sehen
und Frage Nummer 3 2011 sage ich dir
ganz ehrlich ich habe mich so sehr mit
meiner eigenen Musik beschäftigt ein
geiles Album abzuliefern was dir
hoffentlich auch gefallen hat
dass ich wirklich nicht mich so sehr mit
Rap beschäftigt hab aus Deutschland
sondern einfach mein eigenes Ding
gemacht habe und wirklich viel im Studio
gesessen hab viel Zeit dort verbracht
hab von daher kann ich jetzt nicht so
wirklich sagen was 2011 wirklich abging
aber das coole ist ja dass du meine
Musik feierst und mir auf jeden Fall
gratuliert das an der Stelle schöne
Grüße mein
Freund